Traduttore: Valentina Riccarelli
Revisore: Barbara Nettl
(Musica al pianoforte)
Ognuno di noi ha un sogno
che va curato, innaffiato e amato.
Poi frammentato in passi concretizzabili
e umanizzato,
spogliato della sua connotazione poetica
per diventare reale,
però resta sogno.
E "Tutto parte da un sogno"
è l'inizio della mia vita.
Io sono stata il sogno
di una mamma e di un papà
che volevano una figlia,
e dopo mia sorella che si chiama Gioia
sono arrivata io: Disperazione.
Questo ha detto mio papà
qualche anno dopo,
quando ho iniziato a tirare fuori
il mio bel caratterino.
E loro hanno compreso che da questo sogno,
che non aveva proprio i lineamenti
di quello che avrebbero immaginato,
da lì dovevano ripartire
con una concezione nuova:
comprendere che il sogno, che ero io,
andava curato e innaffiato
ma soprattutto andava amato.
Amare è stata la parola chiave
della nostra vita.
Loro mi hanno amata
esattamente così come sono,
e abbiamo capito
che la nostra prospettiva di vita
era un po' diversa
da quella delle altre famiglie
dove in realtà due mani,
che agli occhi degli altri non c'erano,
si sono trasformate in due piedi
oppure, come piace chiamarli a me,
"le mani in basso".
Queste sono le mie mani
che mi permettono di fare
tutto quello che voi fate
con le vostre mani
un po' più in su.
Allora ho subito compreso
che il sogno era proprio quello
che i miei genitori mi stavano mostrando
attraverso la nostra vita.
Quindi trovare qualcosa che si ama,
per cui investire tutto se stesso,
investire le proprie energie,
le proprie passioni.
Allora quand'ero piccola
ho subito iniziato a dipingere.
Mi piaceva tanto sporcarmi di colore
e immaginare delle figure in movimento
attraverso i miei quadri.
E poi il mio corpo,
che quando sentiva una melodia
si muoveva, danzava.
Da piccolina amavo dipingere e danzare
sognando un giorno di farlo davvero.
Lo sognavo e soprattutto
quando mi chiedevano:
"Che cosa vuoi fare da grande, Simona?
Qual è il tuo sogno?"
Io dicevo:
"Voglio fare la pittrice-ballerina."
E un po' come il vostro silenzio
di questo momento,
era la stessa cosa che succedeva
quand'ero piccolina.
(Applausi)
E oltre al silenzio,
il sorriso si smorzava in:
"Poverina, questa bambina
vuole fare la pittrice e la ballerina.
E soprattutto i suoi genitori
non le dicono niente!
Le dicono anche che può farlo!"
Mi rendevo però conto
che ogni volta che ripetevo questa cosa
la reazione che ricevevo dal pubblico
non mi piaceva.
E non capivo se era per i sogni,
perché fare la pittrice e la ballerina
erano due cose un po' strambe.
Anche messe insieme diciamo,
non hanno proprio un grandissimo senso
agli occhi degli altri.
O perché le sognavo io,
una bambina che non aveva le braccia.
Per cercare di capire meglio
ho iniziato a fare dei piccoli test.
Il mio primo piccolo test era quello
di provare a cambiare sogni,
quindi trovare dei sogni
che fossero un po' più conformi
a quello che magari sognavano
le altre bambine.
Quindi la prima volta che mi venne chiesto
"Cosa vuoi fare da grande?"
io dissi: "Voglio fare la maestra!"
Uguale alla reazione di prima:
"Ma come fai a fare la maestra
che devi mettere i piedi sulla cattedra!
Poi i bambini,
come fai a stargli dietro?
Non puoi fare la maestra!"
Anche la maestra non va bene,
proviamone un altro.
Allora mi veniva in mente
la giornalista,
voglio fare la giornalista.
Mi piaceva scrivere, ma mi dicevano:
"Poi come fai a fare le foto,
a fare le interviste, a viaggiare,
andare in giro a incontrare le persone?"
Caspita! Neanche questo va bene.
La mia mamma e il mio papà
non mi dicevano mai niente,
loro non mi dicevano di no.
Dicevo: "O sono matti i miei genitori
o sono matti gli altri".
Quindi non capivo,
non mi quadravano i conti.
Un giorno, tornando con la mamma
in macchina dal dentista le dissi:
"Mamma, ma se io facessi la dentista?"
Mia mamma mi guarda e dice:
"Simo, forse i piedi
in bocca alla gente magari no!"
(Risate e Applausi)
Allora ho capito che non erano i sogni
che non andavano bene.
Non sarebbe andato bene niente.
Agli occhi degli altri non avrei fatto,
non avrei potuto fare nulla.
Fu la prima volta
in cui mi resi davvero conto
che in realtà i veri limiti
sono negli occhi di chi ci guarda.
Per me non erano limiti:
usare miei i piedi come fossero mani
non è un limite.
È la mia realtà, il mio modo di essere,
ciò che in realtà io credo
sono venuta qui a fare.
Però per gli altri era impossibile
e continua a essere impossibile
per alcune persone.
Allora ho compreso una cosa
molto importante e fondamentale
che mi avevano proprio insegnato
i miei genitori
accogliendomi come
un grande dono nella loro vita,
amandomi e dandomi
gli strumenti per crescere,
soprattutto gli strumenti
per credere davvero alle mie capacità,
alle mie potenzialità, ai miei sogni.
Non a quello che gli altri
avrebbero voluto o non voluto,
o per cui gli altri
ci dicevano "non si può".
Così ci siamo presi
tutti questi "non si può",
li abbiamo messi dentro un sacchettino
e li teniamo un po' nascosti.
Non li nascondiamo completamente
perché ogni tanto ci ricordiamo
che si può fare sempre di più
e sempre meglio.
Però allo stesso tempo,
non lasciamo che nessuno
ci possa dire che le cose
non possono essere fatte,
soprattutto se quelle cose partono
dalla parte più profonda di noi.
E i sogni sono questo:
sono ciò che è dentro di noi,
e ci parlano in molti modi
a volte gridando,
a volte in maniera più silenziosa,
a volte anche con un po' di paura,
ma sono quella spinta
che quando diventa talmente forte
diventa calore,
diventa forza,
diventa amore.
È la parola che mi permette
ogni giorno di svegliarmi la mattina,
di scegliere di fare quello che faccio,
di indossare la cosa
più importante che ho
e che è visibile a tutti: il mio sorriso,
il mio biglietto da visita per dire:
"Io ci sono, ci sono così.
Sono stata disegnata
e creata in questo modo,
e in questo modo io faccio ciò
che amo profondamente.
E se lo posso fare io,
lo possiamo fare tutti.
Non ci sono scuse.
Non ci sono "Non si può",
ma solo "Proviamoci".
E passo dopo passo,
giorno dopo giorno,
troviamo il nostro modo,
che può essere diverso
da quello degli altri, ma è il nostro,
per rendere la nostra vita
un vero capolavoro.
Però il mio punto debole sapete qual è?
Dopo che ho parlato tanto,
perché parlo tanto,
dopo che ho dipinto,
e anche lì dipingo tanto,
e anche danzare,
bisogna danzare tanto
perché se no non si può
diventare una ballerina,
mi sento fragile.
Esposta.
E anche se non vorrei mai smettere
di parlare, di danzare, di dipingere,
non vorrei mai smettere
di stare su un palcoscenico
che è la mia seconda casa,
devo farlo, altrimenti potrei disperdermi
negli occhi altrui,
nei vostri occhi.
E allora non sarei più io, Simona.
Quando arriva quel momento io mi inchino.
Mi inchino e ringrazio
chi mi ha dedicato tempo
e soprattutto chi mi ha dedicato cuore.
Sento i miei capelli
che scivolano lungo la schiena
e arrivano a terra,
e quando vedo i miei piedi
inizio a immaginare un nuovo sogno.
(Applausi)
(Musica al pianoforte)
(Musica violino e pianoforte)
(Applausi e acclamazioni)
Grazie.
Beatrice Mazzola.
(Applausi)
Grazie di cuore. Grazie.
Che emozione ragazzi!
Anche lassù... grazie!
Grazie.